[Music]
e4 let's go
okay we're playing the smith mora ladies
and gentlemen once again
the last game for those of you who
weren't here for yesterday's speed run
we won a game of the smith mora in about
18 moves against the 2000 so
yes and we have another smith mora okay
knight f3
let's go again d6 bishop c4 and our last
opponent played knight f6 which is bad
or which is not terrible but a precursor
to
problem so e6 is obviously the main the
main line and we castle then we go queen
e2 and rook d1 that is the
principal setup knight f6
okay now we go queen e2 if i remember
correctly okay queen e2 this is mainline
smith mora and the point of course of
queen e2 if you're not a more a player
is to put the rook on d1y put the rook
on d1 in order to x-ray black's queen
one of the main tenets of the mora is
that with the c file being open the
black queen does not have a good safe
square because on c7 it is vulnerable to
a second rook that appears on c1 and to
the moon knight p5 on b6
it walks into bishop e3 and on a5 it's
just generally awkward and can walk into
all sorts of things so we're essentially
playing against black's queen and our
opponent is stumped so queenie two
clearly surprised him let's see what he
comes up with
did i so question did i read esther's
book on the war a bishop he said when we
go rook t1
uh no i have it but i've i've looked at
bits and pieces so castles now this if i
remember correctly is a mistake black
has to address the threat of e5 here
because
bad things will befall him if he does
and that's why black's main move is
actually to push their pawn to e5
preemptively which creates a lot of
weaknesses and that's the main line if
black doesn't do it then we shove this
pawn forward to e5 and look at the
pressure that we've already developed on
black's pieces now knight okay so let's
be precise i think a lot of people here
would be tempted to play bishop f4 that
would be a very bad move why would that
be a bad move because black is will be
able to push d5 and establish a solid
center that is the worst that is the
worst case scenario so we cannot allow
that to happen so we have to take on d6
first
then after black recaptures on d6 then
we can go bishop f4
and put pressure on whichever piece
appears on the okay so he takes with a
bishop which is interesting let's
consider
the various options in our position so
well from from a
general standpoint
i think it's quite obvious that we we
probably want to exploit the pressure on
the d file right now we have several
ways of doing that i actually do not
like bishop f4 as much
the reason i don't like bishop f4 is
because black can just shift the queen
down to e7 and okay we could trade
bishops but what have we really gained
from that trade so it would be a better
idea here to give up our knight for
black's bishop in order to at least
preserve
the bishop pair i know that there's a
theory move here i don't know what it is
i would imagine that it's an ip5 i would
imagine that it's knight b5 or knight e4
and taking the bishop on d6 getting the
bishop pair now i wouldn't i wouldn't
say that white is winning there or white
is much better
but at least we have the bishop pair and
we have a pretty big initiative so let's
go might be 594 let's go knight b5 i
don't think it really matters which
direction we go with our knight now if
black does not play queen e7 then
obviously we're going to take on d6 and
go bishop f4 and the pin is going to
become deadly so queen e7 here is
derigur
logical logical yeah so some of you are
pointing out this interesting idea once
we eliminate the bishop from d6 we could
think about where our bishop belongs
right and you might say well isn't it
obvious f4 but f4 is not the only square
if we had b3 in we would be able to get
this bishop to a3 that could potentially
create a devastating pin against the
knight on d6 unfortunately that takes
two moves but let's keep that in mind
the possibility of deploying the bishop
to a3
we need seven played good good stuff by
our opponent now we should definitely
take the bishop if we don't take the
bishop the bishop will move and then why
did we play an ip5 right so we take the
bishop
okay and now an import very important
position so
we need to answer a preliminary question
which is are we going to preserve
are we going to preserve
our light squared bishop and
i would imagine that the answer to that
question is no because if we waste a
move actually wait a second it depends
where we put it it depends where we put
it because if we play the move bishop to
d3 right if we play bishop c4 to d3 the
move that concerned me is pawn to e5 why
is that a concerning move to me the
reason it's concerning to me is because
e5 opens up black's light squad bishop
and the worst thing that we can allow
here is for black to completely
consolidate you know what i'm saying so
i have an interesting idea
what if we go not bishop d3 but bishop
b3 who can tell me what is the chief
difference what happens if black plays
e5 here which is not unlikely i think
our opponent might still go e5 what
happens in the event of e5
well in the event of e5 we have an
additional resource
nobody knows
so think about it this exactly the
bishop on b3 is going to pin the pawn on
f7 what does that mean
well that means we can go bishop g5
attacking the queen and black does not
have the critical resource f6 black will
have to move the queen but the queen
doesn't have that many squares to move
to it has to keep its defense of the
knight which means it's only square
after e5 bishop g5 is queen c7 but then
we'll be able to take the pawn on e5
with our knight so that's my idea and it
you have to reverse engineer this
because looking at this move
in and of itself you might say oh this
looks stupid you're just staring at the
pawn on e6 but it's a prophylactic move
right we are preventing
a very important consolidating move okay
b6 by our opponent clearly black wants
to develop to b7 this is a fascinating
position because the question is are we
going to be able to conduct our
initiative
and without allowing i mean if black
needs two moves if black plays bishop b7
and like rook d8 he consolidates he's up
upon so we have to step on the gas pedal
that's what it means to to carry out an
initiative you cannot let your opponent
breathe well what does that mean in the
context of this position well that
probably means developing with tempo so
i know a lot of you are probably
thinking bishop f4 right now and i like
that concept but what i like even more
is starting with bishop g5 i like to
start with this move
not because it attacked the queen we
provoke f6 and then we drop our bishop
back to f4 and also this justifies the
placement of the bishop on b3 e5 is now
illegal why did we provoke f6 for the
simple reason that the e6 pawn is now a
major weakness
why is that important because it
prevents black or at least slows black
down from developing the light squared
bishop knight f7 good move by our
opponent though now we need to keep our
foot on the gas pedal we need to keep
making moves that create threats and
bring pieces into the game but i
i think our opponent is playing
extremely well here rook ac1 seems to
fit the bill
and we're continuing to
put pressure all of our pieces are now
in the game look how nicely everything
is positioned the knight is hanging if
bishop b7 then we take the pawn on e6
and we're groovy the move that i'm
slightly more concerned about is bishop
to d7 because that not only defends the
knight but it keeps the
e6 pawn protected now after bishop d7 i
know that many of you are probably
thinking ah we could still take on e6
little deflection tactic okay knight a5
i think that's a mistake so we can push
that aside because that is not what our
opponent played oh
and i see some juicy stuff
oh my god i see some really cool tactics
here okay
so
the tempting move is rook c7 right rook
c7 is
incredibly tempting but let's not stop
there what happens after roxy said does
this win the game no black plays queen
e8 rook c7 queen e8 and if you look at
that resulting position very carefully
it's actually not obvious that there i
mean we need to find a follow-up there
if we play rook c7 is there a follow-up
in that position
i think there is but bishop d5 here as
many of you are pointing out
looks incredibly good now after bishop
d5 black has a counter resource bishop
a6
with the idea of meeting queen takes a6
with e takes d5 but after bishop d5
bishop a6 what additional move does
white now have
remembering from that's actually why we
played bishop g5 earlier right this is a
recurring theme the e6 pawn is tender so
we can simply grab it and we're going to
have a huge advantage in the
in the end game
let's go bishop d5 it is now you might
say wait a second what about bishop b7
here well bishop b7 we have many moves
we can still take on e6
but we can also contemplate going rook
c7 there
which it's not a given that that's the
best move because black could even sack
the queen for the peace and the rook but
we're spoiled for choice after bishop b7
we're totally spoiled for choice
okay bishop a6 our opponent finds it
okay we play queen takes e6 we
transition into an end game where we
have a big advantage
and look at how how poorly
black's
minor pieces are going to be placed we
have this pin going on the knight we
have the potential threat of playing
b2b4
and when your opponent's pieces are on
the rim like this you can often use your
pawns to limit them even further and to
trap them
rook ae8
so just because the queens are off the
board does not mean
that
we should
take our foot off the gas pedal we
should continue keeping the initiative
alive
what that means in the context of this
position this pin is very important
through the prism of this pin we're able
to keep black's entire position tied
down so i would like to keep this pin
alive so what's a nice move that
activates one of our other pieces
without getting rid of the pin well yeah
we could play bishop d5
but what i like even more
is the move knight to d4 and there is a
very specific reason
that i like this move more than bishop
d5 it actually creates a secondary
threat
that can be very hard to see so i'm
hoping our opponent plays king h8 here i
feel like that would be a very
natural move
which if i calculated it correctly would
result in the loss of a minor piece
what about bishop d6 well bishop d6 is
also a threat
yeah bishop d6 is is another threat for
sure good catch good eye
bishop c that's a great move i was
hoping our opponent wouldn't find that
to be honest i think that's the only
move
yeah our opponent is playing phenomenal
this is very annoying actually somehow
white black is surviving this
aha no i think i see what we need to do
i think i see what we need to do
what should we do well again our top
priority should be
to preserve the pin we have several ways
of doing that rook i love the move
rookie one here rookie one is such a
classy move because it it keeps
everything intact but rookie one i'm a
little bit worried about rook to d8
and the knight on d4 is very tender and
you guys are like well who put the
knight there but we can simply go bishop
d5
we can simply drop the bishop back to d5
now which is a move that
many of you proposed on the previous
move i think it's still good i think
there's nothing wrong with this move
the one thing that concerns me is still
rook d okay bishop b7 yeah i knew he
would play that and now we can win the
exchange who sees
a way that we can win the exchange
and it's not bishop to d6 this would be
a mistake on account of bishop takes d5
and remember that black would get to put
two pieces for the rook
instead we go 96
maybe not the best move maybe taking in
rook c7 would have been even more
precise
but i know for a fact that this wins
material
and it's about time that we wouldn't we
win some material
how does this work well you might say
okay bishop takes d5
we take the rook on f8
the bishop is going to be hanging so if
black takes the knight we take the
bishop our back rank is safe that's
important to establish both of our rooks
are on the back rank which means that
one of them could depart the background
can we'd still be okay right but the
thing you have to establish is that
after bishop d5 knight f2 for example
bishop takes a2
is the knight going to be trapped
well i already made that determination
it's not because the knight could have
escaped to d7 okay our opponent just
folds over
king takes f8 is not serious and now
we're up a full exchange this is
completely winning
knight c4
obviously we are not taking it
now the way to win such positions
quickly is to aim for maximum peace
activity as quickly as possible
so rather than going b3 here which i
think is an automatic instinct for a lot
of people rather than playing the move
b3 i think a more
decisive way to approach this position
would be to
go rook d7 just get the rook to the
seventh rank and the point is that once
the knight i mean this is debate which
you bait the knight once it takes on b2
it is stranded on b2 it can't go back
assuming we make some lift
right if we don't make any luft the
knight can come back to c4 and then we
won't be able to capture it so rook
takes a7 knight c4 is not efficient
what we should do here is just make some
luft and i like to play the move h4 in
such situations because it also
discourages black from pushing his own
kingside pawns
in fact g5 is likely but i'll show you
what happens if you play g5 our next
move is going to be what
essentially against anything our next
move is going to be rook c to c7 and
what i want you to notice
if you're trying to extract lessons for
how to play the end game what you should
notice is that i am not going for any
pawns yet
right i had several opportunities
to play materialistically the first came
here we could have played b3 to preserve
our b pawn the second game here we could
have taken an a7 in both situations
i'm prioritizing peace activity at all
costs over
you know meaningless and temporary
positional gain now and only now
when push has come to shove okay we can
take on a7 but only because it serves
the secondary purpose of keeping the
rook on the seventh rank not because
this is a pawn we also had the move
bishop d6 jack by the way which would
have won on the spot
knight d3 and i saw this
and there is a key detail what should we
do in this position have we succumbed to
a fork
have we missed this
yeah rook d1 actually is winning
although it's a little bit convoluted
that's not the best move don't lose
sight of our main goal which is to play
rook c7
we play rook cc7 attacking
counter-attacking counter-attacking then
knight on f7 and the game is over that's
it once we get our rooks to the seventh
we're just gonna take everything on the
seventh rank and it's gonna be mate
piggies on the seventh okay so knight
takes f4
we obviously take on f7
okay so how do we win this efficiently i
think some people in such a position
have the instinct to trade rooks we
absolutely do not need to trade rooks we
simply start by taking all of his pawns
and now
again
rather than okay we can trade rooks yeah
we can we can play rook g7 if you want
to trade rooks which is the simplest way
to win this at this point trading a pair
of rooks is very simple we play rook a
to g7 check
and now who can tell me
what is the way to trade rooks in such a
position and this is a method by the way
that you can apply in rook end games
across many different types of end games
rook h8 check yes
with 30 seconds on the clock it's a good
idea to trade here
now what should be the approach to
winning this position
the approach is to create an outside
passer so we should create the past a
pawn
and then we should push that pawn to
promotion
and this is easy plenty of time
we push the pawn
i'm going to throw in the move g3 for
good measure rook b6
now notice that i'm not removing this is
very important look at the relationship
between the rook and the knight this is
something to remember the knight just
cannot access any key squares
now we play a6
i'm not in time trouble this is not
called time trouble this is
i can take three seconds on a moon i'd
be fine which is exactly what i'm doing
in fact
all right we're good
i love the acting like no time trouble
ever no we we
i also could have played a lot faster
when we won the exchange so relax
everybody
if i wanted to i could have played
much much faster from this position
onwards thank you anjali
but
i will alert you if i'm an actual time
pressure like you'll probably see it on
my face i'll be actually more focused
and intense
okay
all right so mark
i'm sure analyzes the move
uh e5 here or rather
castles okay so the main move here is e5
there is also queen c7 which is a
sideline
but the main move is e5
and then the main line goes h3 castles
bishop e3
bishop e6
bishop b6 fe 6
okay there's like a gazillion different
sub variations here you can uh check out
mark's book this is the main line or the
traditional main line
now the question is wouldn't e5 make a
backwards pawn yes it would right i'm
not denying that e5 has drawbacks but
it's the the priority for black is to
prevent white from playing e5
and you are up upon so it's okay that
you now have a backward pawn if that
makes sense
okay
castles
e5
and maybe e5 isn't even the best move i
mean i i wouldn't
jump to that conclusion it's just so
natural that i would be shocked if it
wasn't
but i'm saying in the opening explorer
that bishop f4 is also a move apparently
let me see
e5 is best so we're being told by the
resident smith mora expert
that e5 is best
okay
so e5 98 ed6 i wonder where we deviated
from mark's book
okay so let me look at the index here
yeah e5 98 e6 bishop d6 knight p5 x-clam
the knight b5 is correct
queen e7
this is mayhem and the mora mark
esterman bishop g5x clem so this is a
mistake taking on d6 is a mistake or
maybe not a mistake but not accurate
bishop g5 is the best move
so we induce f6 oh so this is an idea
that we applied in the game
but this is a better
application of it
bishop b8 rook ac one
the heavy piece storm never relents the
mora rooks reach their natural squares
and the game of hide and seek nears its
conclusion hide and seek with the queen
by the way i mentioned this at the start
the gambits here now menaces bishop c5
followed by bishop takes e6 check
winning
so for instance a6 bishop c5
queen c5 bishop takes e6 jack
bang
the knight on b5 is just very nicely
placed by the way this is probably why
you want knight b5 as opposed to 94. use
the process of comparison don't just
like you can compare like 94 queen e7
if you do the same thing here
actually i guess this does have actually
a plus to putting the 994 which is that
bishop b8 now there's bishop c5
skewering
the queen
yeah the writing is beautiful so maybe
94 is also good but i would trust mark
yeah so bishop g5 f6 bishop e3 thank you
daniel fan
rook ac1b6
bishop b3 x-clam
white remains upon down but the rooks
are chewing up the board
creating decisive threats against
black's minor pieces
black is bullied to the back rank a
theme you'll see throughout the book
bishop b7
bang
bang
bang plus minus oh my god what a line
and the hunt finally ends
white's forces doggedly swarmed the
queen never letting her out of their
sights
beautiful
this is a really cool line so the move
is bishop g5
and this is the the benefit of actually
having chess books right having access
to information beautiful line so bishop
g5 is the move
we decided to take and go bishop b3
because i'm a plebe and i don't know the
smith mora but this is a very difficult
position for black regardless so once
again the the idea of bishop b3 as
opposed to bishop d3 is that i wanted to
discourage black from playing e5
i wanted to discourage black from
playing e5 now does it make sense
why e5 is should be discouraged like why
is this a scary move well this is a
scary move because it controls more of
the center and mainly it opens up
black's light squared bishop so if we
think about the sources of white's
compensation why do we have full
compensation for the pawn here we can
point to a couple of things the first is
that we have the bishop pair in
particular we have an uncontested dark
squared bishop so black has weaknesses
on a lot of the dark squares so for
example if the queen ever goes to c7 we
have bishop f4 that's all because we
have a dark squared bishop
black is a bad light-squared bishop
which is hemmed in by his own pawns we
have the d-file
and we also kind of have dibs on the c
file like we can bring our rook faster
to c1 all of that stuff kind of
evaporates if we allow black to play e5
so that's why i played bishop b3 because
if e5 then we play bishop to g5 f6 is
illegal that's the whole point
and queen c7 runs into knight takes e5
i think we're in good shape here
okay
so b6 black tries to
his light square bishop and now bishop
g5 simple concept provoking f6 and now
dropping the bishop back to f4
just
make a note to yourself this is
important right sometimes you can ask
yourself like you know you want to
develop the bishop here but can you
can you provoke a weakness first and
then drop the piece back to the square
you initially wanted to put it on right
that's that's like a a pattern that you
can use in many many different types of
positions and it should make sense why
provoking f6 is good for us it could
backfire
it actually could backfire under what
circumstances who can answer me this
question under what circumstances could
provoking f6 actually backfire
if if what piece was on what square
would we not want to allow the move f6
if exact very good if the black king was
on h8 we would actually be helping black
play e5 so everything is relative in
chess everything depends on the position
at hand
exactly very good so if the king was on
h8 we would have to settle for bishop f4
but here because the king is on g8 we
play this knight f7
now we bring our rook into the game of
tempo
again here we directly use the weakness
of e6 if bishop b7 bang we take on e6
bishop d7
was the move that i
expected from our opponents
so did you see bishop d5 of the opponent
playing no i honestly only saw rook c7
but i knew that we would have other
resources as well because our position
is so overwhelming
okay so what do we do what do we do
if black plays bishop d7
what is our idea here who can propose
an interesting move here let's analyze
this position a little bit
okay so i want to hear a couple
candidate moves i want to hear a couple
of candidate moves and then we'll i'll
tell you what i was thinking if that
i'll give you guys a second to think
about this i think i had a really
interesting idea in mind
okay so bishop d6 blunders the bishop
knight takes d6 so
the sort of move that you would play if
you're tactically alert
is bishop take c6 bishop takes c6 is
wrong the problem with bishop takes c6
it's hard to evaluate moves that look
cool because you're already predisposed
to want to play them right you you feel
good about yourself and you play this
move but let's actually calculate what
happens here
black plays queen takes e6
right and as a consequence of this what
have you gained well you've
reestablished material equality not for
long as we will see but you've you've
traded all of the pieces you your entire
initiative has evaporated you've cashed
in
your initiative for a measly pawn and
not even that because if you calculate
until the end of the line you will see
that black can safely take the pawn on
a2 now i don't think that white's
necessarily worse here i think that
after something like rook c7 you could
argue that white's rook activity gives
full compensation for the pawn but this
is clearly not the way to win the game
right does that make sense you have to
calculate such lines to their natural
conclusion bishop d6 blunders the bishop
that's why he put a knight on f7 that
doesn't work either
another proposal from some people
was the move rook takes d7 that has to
be calculated
unfortunately
i don't think it works either queen
takes d7 bishop takes c6 right
and
i feel like black can even drop the
queen back to e8 and despite appearances
i feel like black is holding everything
together
i mean queen c4 you could try to
pressure black but
there are really no threats here
i mean knight a5 i feel like this gets
really really chaotic and
it's not clear to me that white is full
compensation what about bishop a4 after
the exchange cycle bishop a4 after the
exchange stack black and defend the
night with the rook aca
the knight can be protected too many
times you can you will not be able to
win this night
okay
so now let me tell you what my idea was
now that i gave you some chance some
time to think about this position
my intended move and i'm not claiming
that this is the best move or that this
is such an amazing move i'm just going
to tell you how i thought about this
the bishop on d7 is a type 2 undefended
piece a while ago i introduced these
concepts in the first speed run a type 1
undefended piece
is a piece that is unprotected by any
other pieces or pawns a type 2
undefended piece is a piece that is only
protected by one other piece
right and any piece that's protected by
a pawn is automatically considered
defended
so how many type 2 undefended pieces
does black have
well there's two of them there's the
knight on c6 which is only protected by
the bishop
and there's the bishop which is only
protected by the queen
now the technically technically the rook
on a8 is also a type two undefended
piece but
the point of these concepts is to help
you look at the position you're not
gonna there's gonna be no tactic that
exploits this rook on it it's out of the
way completely
right so
you could think about that and say okay
the bishop on d7 when i look at this
position it looks vulnerable to me
right when i look at this position i'm
like okay the rook's pressuring the
knight the other expression in the
bishop there's something about this
construction
that seems very vulnerable to me so i
would start by exploring ways in which
we could put pressure on either the
bishop or the knight
now one way we could put pressure on the
knight is bishop a4 some of you proposed
this move unfortunately black is an easy
way to defend the knight rook aca but
let's consider whether we can attack the
bishop what if we play the move queen d2
or queen d3
well this is a little bit more meaty
because you might say wait a second
black can just go rook ft8 but don't
stop calculating here white has a
devastating move and arty bear found it
and that move is bishop f4 to c7
attacking the rook dislodging it and
then winning the bishop or the exchange
so my intended move is actually queen d3
attacking the bishop the bishop is only
one square and that's e8 and i already
think that white has gained a lot by
forcing this incredibly awkward move to
appear on the board
can't you add another attack or two
after bishop not really you don't have
any attackers i don't know i don't know
if i would have played queen d32 one of
these two moves here
i even would consider bishop to d6 now
and if you consider that what happens
after the trade well after the trade
white gets a tremendous initiative even
the i mean look at look at the piece
activity here and black is really really
really tied down
so maybe black is okay here but i
figured that this would be a very
interesting practical chance
what if knight e5
where oh if 95 here then we just take it
we win the piece because we're defending
the e5 square enough times to where
eventually the bishop is going to be
undefended
so queen d3 or queen d2 was my intended
move
but the main thing you have to see is
rook d8 bishop c7 this is actually the
main line
if you don't see this this move then
you're not going to play queen d3 in the
rook takes d7 line was there bishop f7
for white it goes on side grower
here here here
oh there actually is
look at look at you that's a great move
i didn't see bishop takes f7
that's a that's a phenomenal move
because because if the queen takes then
you drop the knight
and if the rook takes then you take the
queen and then you take the knight and
the knight defends e1
okay so i would have to amend my thought
there and say that okay queen b7
queen b7 is probably what would deter me
from this
i hope my thought process was clear on
why i would play queen d3
in the game why plays black plays knight
a5
how do you find the move bishop d5 well
in general
you know anytime you have a piece that
has no squares left
you should thank you chill bersaurus rex
for the prime there we go
now i'm starting to kill people and neb
livion with a prime
so anytime you have a situation like
this where the rook has no squares
you should automatically think about
ways to attack it
in addition consider the standoff
between the queens black's queen is a
type 1 undefended piece which means that
the pawn is pinned which means that you
should see bishop d5 right that's not a
hard move to see you should see it
this is a move that you should see
the thing is rook c7 first
we cannot switch the move order if we
play rook c7 and then bishop d5 the
queen is now defended
so that's not possible
one piece of advice i would have for you
is if you find yourself looking at this
and saying it unless you're a beginner
right if you're like 14 or 1500 you're
like i don't see bishop d5 and i feel
like i would never see this move
when my students say this phrase i i
push back and i say why do you say that
like what is it about this move that you
think you would never see what aspect of
the position
do you have a hard time identifying and
then whichever
aspect of the position you feel like
doesn't occur to you naturally is what
you need to spend more time on uh
in general when you need to spend more
time on thinking about so bishop d5
attacking the rook and trapping it
bishop a6 and now we redirect and we
take on e6
by the way if bishop b7
then we have rook c7 if we wanted that's
a fork
yeah looking for undefended pieces is
really the majority of tactical thinking
in general
obviously e takes d5 blunders the queen
so
everything checks out here
bishop a6 queen e6 and now we transition
into this end game or we're much better
rather than just dropping the bishop
back we preserve we preserve the pin and
the last comment that i wanted to make
in this game because the rest of the
game was very obvious what happens if
black plays king h8 in order to unpin
the knight on f7 so all of a sudden we
play b4
we play b4
okay the knight's hanging knight b7
now we play bishop f7 we give up that
bishop and then we trap black's bishop
with b5
okay one at a time
can you explain rook c7
what do you mean well we didn't play it
though where where would you like me to
explain it wasn't bishop d6 winning in
exchange well i explained this during
the game the other bishop is hanging
black takes on e6 and then black takes
on f8 and black gets two pieces for the
rook which is not good for white
right so you have to defend this bishop
first so knight d4
bishop c no it's all good
yeah loose pieces drop off is good
because it's been around for a long time
bishop d5 zen move just drop the bishop
back
clear the e6 square for the knight
threaten bishop d6 and obviously a
computer could probably defend this for
black but from a human perspective this
is garb i mean this is this is
horrible miserable
it should be set and now 96 and now we
have to calculate right bishop takes d5
knight takes f8 now more resilient by
our opponent would have been to take on
a2
but then our knight has a very safe
square on d7 where it is protected by
the rook on d1 how did rook c7 work with
the fork oh absolutely
if we rewind a little bit i made a
poorly explained point if bishop b7 i
said
we have the possibility of playing rook
c7 why is this a fork well what are we
forking right well we're attacking the
queen right
the bishop defends the rook so that's
good and if the queen moves away then we
have one two attackers on b7 and black
is only one defender so we can take on
b7 and win a piece but but if you are in
the situation with black and if you were
listening carefully to how i was
describing this
what should black do in this position
what is the most resilient defensive
move for black queen d8 does not help we
still take on b7 this actually makes
things worse
take the rook yes so people forget about
this all the time the concept of giving
up your queen
for a significant amount of material you
can give your queen
for a rook and a piece
black has
a knight a rook and a pawn for the queen
white is better no question that white
is better
just the last point here is that the
critical aspect of playing these
positions is
to focus on peace activity rather than
focusing on pawns
so of course you could win the game by
playing b3 but i really wanted to
illustrate the impact
of two active rooks and what get what
that can do to your position i mean
this is a complete game trip we don't
give a damn about the b2 pawn and the
game-winning move is h4 we're creating
luft we're setting up rook c7 and we're
basically playing that move against
anything what would you do after rookie
7 what would be white's most accurate
move here who can tell me
yeah so we want to give this check
row comes back to it and now rook c7
classic technique just remember this
technique
and uh
the game is over and that's it after
rook d8 we take on a7
we get the other rook to the seventh
rank counter attacking
the knight on f7
we take on f7 take g7 takes h7 and now
the classic technique to trade rooks in
such a position
rook g7 king f8 bang rook h8 forcing the
king to take we take the rook on d8 and
we win the game easily
okay so the the the interesting part of
this game really occurred in the first
25 30 moves
uh you know after that it was just
completely winning end game but look at
the pressure that we managed to put with
the smith mora
and so i think we're beginning to prove
that the smith mora it survives
even the highest level
and i think that's what makes mark's
book so amazing it it's not he's not
just giving you like gimmicky analysis
you know this is analysis at like a
title player level so this is a lifetime
opening provided of course
that you study knight f6 very carefully
because at higher levels people begin
playing this
and the alapan sicilian is by no means
boring
and if you want to hear something
interesting if you want a little bit of
inspiration
so i have another book
yeah i had a winning position against
another beatman whaley this is called
squeezing the sicilian it's on the
alpine it's 400 pages i would say about
200 of them are on knight f6 so if
you're a moro player
you need to realize that this is also an
interesting line this is not a draw this
is not dry
this is very much in
congruent with the types of positions
you want to get i used to play the
alpine
full-time until i was about 1900 we
played it on the first speed run
so if you want to learn more about this
particular line
i would start i think mark might propose
queen takes d4 which is an interesting
sideline you can look this up as well
this is legit it has
you know it it's it's sensible but if
you want to play the main lines you can
look at all of the alpine games from my
speedrun
and you shouldn't just get discouraged
every time somebody plays knight f6
because this is also a cool line
so my official like nereditskiy
recommendation
uh in
against c5 is either the alpine or the
mora or as usually happens a combination
of both
okay
[Music]